alright we're switching gears here Brad  Pitt wasn't at the British Academy Film  Awards to accept this trophy for Best  Supporting Actor and once upon a time in  Hollywood but his speech as delivered by  his co-star Margot Robbie in front of  the Royals was one of the most memorable  moments of the life watch this  hey Britain heard you just became single  welcome to the club says that he is  gonna name this Harry cuz he is really  excited about bringing it back to the  states with him the Duke and Duchess of  Cambridge who were of course good sports  they laughed off the joke it clearly  took aim at Prince Harry and Megan  Marvel's decision to step down as Royals  you could see brother William going this  is not  you